what is up there citizens of the reject
Nation we're gonna watch the final
episode of this season of black mirror
today I want to thank everyone who has
been on this journey with us we thought
the show would be bigger yes not but hey
for those who have decided to stick
around with us we appreciate you that
much more John how's it going I am great
I'm ready for whatever this is about to
be how are you I'm doing well Johnny Boy
ladies gentlemen leave a like hold a
mirror up to yourself and see that you
are holding a like button also
full-length Reaction watch along where
you sing with their own copy of Black
Mirror available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page thank
you to everyone who has joined just for
this show alone we've actually gotten a
lot of patrons just due to this one
Series so thank you very much we also
cover many things over there exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included so this show is big
enough alrighty guys let's swing into
action
[Music]
hell yes
definitely in the 70s
I've never seen such 4K film grain
before yeah
digitally rendered to perfectly emulate
the look of film
[Music]
cinematography and Framing and these
zooms are certainly doing the trick
somehow already invested in her day
I like getting to know a character just
through images
[Music]
that's Perfection right there you could
be that got a customer I'm on my lunch
yeah I can smell that mine's in five
minutes so if I start with a customer
now it cuts into my break
so come off yours
that's Keith holigan sir
he murdered his wife oh it was
manslaughter
surely we don't have to serve him
everyone needs shoes neither
how about doing your job
go help the nice manslaughterer I think
I'm going to need the 11.
I'm large
from a height
yeah look at this is it
I wonder if that was a character Choice
sure you can't do a discount I'm so
sorry no we can I'm just a bit strapped
till the end of the month I can put them
aside for you
if you fancy writing down your number I
won't mind oh yeah do it
[Music]
yeah
it's a nice like
cheeky editing the donation has suffered
through a winter of discontent now they
promised us a brighter future labor
isn't working
Michael's smart you're gonna have to
look around to see it rubbish in the
streets
crime on the
on the threat excellent I refuse to
think this has anything to do with her
race
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
as the election near polisher Mrs
Thatcher's conservative party retains a
commanding need you're going to bring
your visualizations to life
Russia long ago he was big and strong
and his eyes are faming low
I really don't make him like that
anymore I understand you're in the
habits of eating your lunch in the
stockroom we don't mind but it's
it's what you're eating oh God you see
most people's food
um normal food it doesn't tend to linger
afterwards oh my so if you must eat in
there maybe just bring in a sandwich
like a chick like a cheese and ham
sandwich or just a cheese sandwich you
know if you're one of those that doesn't
do happen
oh my yes
yes I did bring the Biryani in today
well eat in the street yes find an
alleyway
how about the basement even better
murder yeah you want to do it go ahead
beat her head and do something
yes
nice
hello what you want
cool
let's bring some of these mannequins to
life make them do your bidding be like
that Doctor Who episode
so the man who used to work here left
paper clip cutouts of his allegations
yeah of his entire life story
oh
is she looking at the string
get that string
Oh I thought she was looking at the pick
oh I was joking it's pretty obvious for
sure
red herring
you Bond it to it now
yep
it's disconcerting with the mannequins
yeah well done show well done
[Music]
whoa
it's sweet
it's like an evil totem
uh yeah all right so my name's Dart I'm
a demon you're known this tattoosman
with your blood so now we're back
together
crush it now and so I'll be over oh man
don't embrace your Darkness you were not
into Talisman and the rules are you've
got to carry out free human sacrifices
over the next three days or else the
world's gonna win
if you want me to help you you need to
permit me entry cool you'll never hear
from me again like this didn't happen
just say yes say it say it come on say
it say it say it say it say it
is the kind of notes I would pass in
school you said yes way too fast too
much of a pushover
oh no crew and extra lines
foreign
apparently this is a physical look you
find a feeling so hell yes it's Blood
and Bone you know you marked the
Talisman I don't make the rules I mean
basically we need to deliver free
sacrifices by Mammoth I was burning
Skies time all right let it burn I think
she needs some convincing uh
let me show you how this will play out
three two one
whoa
my apartment's gonna burn down
and I don't have it insured for
disasters
[Applause]
[Music]
Nate
[Applause]
some really weird editing yeah
and to be honest I don't want the
apocalypse to come about any more than
you do so let's stop it happening you
and me all you have to do is deliver
free days it's really well edited yeah
that is fewer people desire falling off
ladders in the same time period you'd be
less lethal than a ladder
under your belt stop racking them up
killing anyone you actually think of
these two people you want to kill three
oh yeah well support so just hold on to
that break let's go flag someone
brick
in your hand love
are you all right
I Need a Doctor you want me to go and
call one this guy's horrible helping out
the city oh my name's Laura she's eight
years old
the bastard makes her feel get load of
this
oh he could be making all this up
still true yeah
she kills herself age 28 exhausted by
the pain and the shame of it
okay okay
oh that poor dog has no idea what's
happening
good thing you waited till you got back
to throw up a couple more throws and
I'll be out of your head see one line
gone that's one sacrifice registered two
to go pick the next one
so very practical
person boy or girl uh man
it's okay Laura
this lady are going to help find daddy
she doesn't want that
oh
you're late for work you're gonna have
to go in you know you can't have people
getting suspicious I mean if you don't
turn off you should talk
but this time they'll be right they'll
be totally bloody right you're not crazy
I'm a murderer you're being a crazy one
perfectly sane logical murderer
I'm not a bad person I don't know it
wouldn't work if you are it has to be
someone corruptable
oh Jesus
calling the police what why I know I
know okay you don't want the brother
three sacrificial victims on your hands
but if it saves billions
trolley problem why would the demon care
to save everyone though carry on as
usual so the normals don't get spooked
which means going to work
we can decide who to kill next
yeah make that decision real quick
I don't care what anyone says this is to
be my favorite episode yeah
a lot of fun
run off the algae
I think
No actually that's still from the till
you know she's steals from the two
she can't stop thinking about the end
though they can't wait for it to come
you'd be you'd be doing her a favor
what was that
[Music]
turned a buzzy
yeah but he's dead
wow
someone's clobbered him sir it's
clobbering time
oh nice
what time do you finish depends what
time you want to start huh right now I
won't want to stop here
do you want the apocalypse open you're
in the way
I love this plot it's so simple
oh geez so rich yeah
you know no you're not you're not a nice
person way too grabby got your hands all
out
that's you you're a Basher that's
courage hey I don't drink
yeah [__] yeah we're going out
but do you want a drink
let's go I choose to believe the demon
is real but I like them uh infused in
the real world of war tensions yeah
because that it makes you question
whether or not it's real there's all
just in her head
all sorts of plausible explanations yeah
triple Scotch please there you see he's
still got work today
actually make it two triple scotches
thank you I don't have to get one for me
I didn't uh oh he's gonna be begging her
to stop by the end of this
three years ago before his wife was
cheating oh hell yeah Keith
Johnny wasn't premeditated but he did
have a hard on when he did it so
oh should Grace you embrace it
hit me chug
he's following me from Bob you're a dog
also yeah I've read about girls like you
oh sure you have I'm just round corner
you know what aren't Earth even better
I watch sense him being shy now
it's still dangerous for her though sure
he could overpower her
oh yeah what are the what's good demons
gonna do if she actually gets killed
right now so it's midnight you're
cutting it fine okay what was that
can't wait to [__] you
ah
a
tell you what you you get comfy I'll
just go and have a wash down there first
it is 11 54. six minutes left since you
asked
and from behind
oh dude come on
you're gonna hit me with that
I always knew something would happen
oh
ever since I did it
oh wow
well I deserve
I can honestly did a little bit at least
I'm editing one's the demons some
credibility too just egg around man and
Hell
knew this guy didn't live alone
oh geez get that third one in early that
has to be one a day but if it's like two
minutes to midnight now she get us 1201.
okay
no no eyewitnesses
please
oh golly
that's so awkward yes
it's real
throw it at his head oh boy
[Music]
is kill gonna count
get it password Maybe
there we go oh you are a stabber
I wonder if it's gonna fall on a
technicality
would not be surprised
oh
oh let's give it another stab yeah enjoy
it just come on go ahead and enjoy it
check the time
counts
I'm gonna go back and check the time and
that's he's gonna do tonight
our one today is just the minimum but
two it doesn't get you over the line get
down there oh so it does count
see it um I guess
no yeah nope he's wrong
Circle 1926 uh but the room face has
failed to register one of the sacrifices
I mean yeah but
well we
didn't can why he's a murderer but we've
been picking people who deserve it I
mean it was strictly supposed to do it
that way I just
I thought you'd find it easier oh my God
but basically anyone that has already
been directly responsible for the death
of another human being they're off
limits oh good thing she got two tonight
then I failed my initiation I kicked out
of demons called boo who cast out into a
boundless Cosmic void
better than apocalypse infinite
nothingness
absence of matter of time
space light and sand this poor demon
alone
in perpetuity
forevermore
wow
comfort him
but through a hard time
she's made as we have to avoid you mean
people like me
a whole life I never wished harm on
anyone yeah okay I mean you can summon
me from my trial if you hadn't
pissed you off
there we go
might as well
here's Nida stop that you can deal with
a kid out there needs black shoes for a
few
they pulled his heart look now
ah you spared her another five years of
it a lifetime of therapy but a lifetime
nonetheless I believe in therapy
well Scientology says it's the tools of
the devil so of course
I insist too late here we are oh he
kills mayor let's get all three well I
said I'd leave you in hands of our
finest assistant so um Vicky
she could take care of Michael Michael
oh my God just kill the whole store just
bludgeoned them all with shoes so wait
till he comes out reverse into him up
against the wall keep the pedal down to
your head a stomach pop
National front for me don't like how
things are changing around here oh my
God
you know what I don't Prince stop
immigrate
regress is on my campaign
because look at me
looks like Thomas Jane
you know what I stand for
somebody glamored her to have your vote
yes sir
good girl
oh
you devil you haven't got long what's
his future Michael smart uh can you show
me his future
I love this
417. that's not just different they're
in theory they're even expelled from the
Tories Michael smart launched his new
the rivers of blood are here yes
Victory Britain has a new prime minister
what's coming Rising seats wow
why not kill this guy
is not one of us not literally
technically yeah can I choose Michael
smart he's the one in that well honestly
they are not gonna like it but it's
within the rules that they can lump at
yes go oh he's created someone he wants
to try an 11. hurry up it's gone Closing
Time Still's there do it yourself yeah
let me harder to spot blood on that
thing too
[Music]
you've changed
that'll be the hot new fashion next week
all right winning last night he's in
most nights anything unusual about him
well he killed his wife
sat on his purse dragging his pants up
left around Closing Time anyone follow
him over well that's all
oh no the other bartender Lady it's
Indian loss never been in before drunk
two triple scotches by yourself can you
describe her yeah Indian
hey is that over there
sorry talking to herself Works in shoes
at posits
did they yeah
I thought that was her face do you mind
if I have a word yeah sure inside
environment and then kill him
you're in the pub last night the three
crowns to be honest last night was the
first time just around the corner isn't
it well I don't drink
not usually
yesterday was Mom's birthday
well done yeah oligan's Heath and Chris
I've not heard of them I'm afraid looks
like you served him at work a few days
ago oh
we get so many in the door
to be honest by the end of the day I
hardly recognize myself
so you didn't see him
I certainly didn't notice him
so sorry it wasn't more helpful
I'm impressed he didn't boiler that's
hurry then
smart will be finishing his speech
are you getting followed yeah I'm gonna
have a back door or something this
election may decide Our Fate will that
fate his eyes to decide
so don't just hope for a better future
vote for one
get him got a bad feeling about this
[Applause]
[Music]
I am driving gloves
so fancy
oh that'd be so perfect just push him
into the train I know
oh Lord
[Music]
Italian Job perfect
you're an officer of the law just get
out and badge the train man I want her
to get away with it
you know it's not too late to just find
someone else shut up I'm just saying it
would be much easier for me if you just
find someone else's you're not gonna
help them piss off fine
I mean if she's gonna do it she wants to
feel Justified and that she's providing
Justice I wonder if she's just gonna
drive right into him maybe she doesn't
want to live through this
foreign
yes
wow
[Music]
make sure the job the deed is done
before the cop gets there hurry run run
won't help me then
[Music]
hurry stop milking it yeah
I have to do it
you know
if I don't do this by midnight that'll
be wrong
we'll deal with if it comes to it oh
sorry
okay
we're so close each time you sacrifice
someone it got registered on the
Talisman is that right this is a
Talisman yeah
no it's called normal now
before was it chest in her head the
demon who told you to do all this and
what did he look like like a monster at
first then he turned into the man from
born again oh no
tell her why he did that it'll make more
sense Insanity plea
my mother feels sorry for her no matter
how much sympathy mine must have for a
personal situation
it's from this morning
oh hell yeah yeah
[Music]
yes
burn it all
where you at gab you're already off in
the void just got word they are casting
me out and eternal Oblivion
so sorry
if you want to come with me oh that
means nice they don't say anything about
a human companion into Eternal Oblivion
I know it's much less than that
it's with me
[Music]
true damnation
okay cool
oh
[Music]
I bet you feel really bad now huh yeah
sure let that man die
oh wow
[Music]
that's awesome
how sweet I love this
Toby Haynes I know that name
I don't hear anyone really talk about
that episode but I loved it yeah I think
that's my favorite one I don't think I
know for sure that's 100 my favorite one
and that has the least to do with
technology yeah what is that there's a
receipt machine that they used to track
her link to that one guy they just went
completely Supernatural with that one
yeah or the technology of nuclear war
and all that
which is a technological advancement
sure
uh but it's a cool old history take
that was fun that was great I loved it I
loved it so much I love such a simple
premise that is all about the nuance and
the relationships
and watch Finding this optimistic ending
at the end for because it's like the
whole world gets doomed but I'm so aware
we're living in an alternate reality
with this show that I'm like yeah I'm
down burn the world don't care burn it
all down I just want to see her be happy
yeah and then at the end they get it and
they have
incredible chemistry those two just the
the perform and they both get an arc
I could not believe what I was watching
that was so well done yeah I I could
give a [__] if people don't like it that
was awesome no that was that was that
was really awesome with some awesome
stylist flourishes throughout
45 second opinion done John would you
think yeah no I love the way this snaked
through tones and really just relished
in the question mark of its you know
whole Central premise like you know you
start out with what clearly feels like
okay we're homage and some kind of
paranoid 70s satanic movie but I thought
their subversions to and twists on that
tone it worked nicely to establish
something
that embodied both the twisted humor and
the foreboding you know uh doomishness
that Black Mirror can often come with
but in a totally other way and yeah like
to have the central relationship that
starts out in such a
you know with such you know opposition
and tension that then you know goes
through all these shifts and power
changes until the point where they're
finally both at the end and resigned and
and it becomes this sort of Twisted
Little Love Story uh yeah that was was
beautiful and and like you know this
season has been in some ways more
Fantastical thus far but uh I like what
they've been doing with those
Fantastical elements and yeah something
like this I think plays nicely because
it's something you'll hear echoed like
oh you know this person who killed such
and such amount of people like was
convinced of you know some kind of
Apocalypse scenario or some you know
message from a higher or lower power and
yeah I thought there's their trade from
her living in the oblivions of life to
them living together in the oblivions of
the afterlife like
Eternal damnation but also like you know
getting off kind of easy away from the
rest of the world yeah so is like so
sweet while also being really harsh and
nasty and and you know stomach churning
at points the way again I think Black
Mirror does
um
and two I think you know while it's
while they're not necessarily always
leading with like you know the
commentary this season I still think
that there are like this episode is a
lot of nice and and interesting and
harsh flourishes of you know just the
political Spectrum Circa you know the
70s and the Cold War and things like
that but also things that are certainly
relevant to the here and now like as
much as it feels removed from now it
also doesn't you know
um no I I don't think it feels I don't
think it feels removed at all and
especially with with the
the person running for mayor was his
whole diabolical plan and his big end
game going down the road they interspice
it with footage that looked modern day
and then footage that looked futuristic
at the same time of what the
kind of
political Wars they would ultimately
land into due to this one guy
and that
once he
once he lived I was like okay
this is God they did have they did have
me fold for a hot minute it was it was
when the clock turned midnight and then
nothing happened which was gonna bum me
out I wanted it to be real I wanted
everything to end I wanted the world to
incinerate yeah
so when they come around to that I was I
was relieved but I had an inkling that
because he lived I was like okay yeah
this has to be this has to be real but I
do like that it plays on the whole thing
of
um like a joker or even uh what was that
Scientology riff movie that Paul Thomas
Anderson did no the master yeah kind of
like the master both Joaquin Phoenix
performances but also a bit of like
Henry portrait of a serial killer this
innocent timid but not enter Portugal it
was not that but the the archetype of a
innocent timid character who arcs into
embracing her own inner demons and then
finds confidence within herself by the
end of the journey uh I think is it was
a great character Arc that I found very
believable and every little moment of
her
seem that like you knew where the
trajectory of her performance was headed
it could have gone down a path where she
just becomes completely sadistic and
just really wants to kill and become a
badass he becomes a badass or becomes
very diabolical it could have gone down
a whole number of paths that went to a
further extreme but they managed to
even though she murdered
they managed to maintain her humanity
and a moral compass within that while
letting that Darkness also live on the
surface as well so they kept it in this
complex gray area that I was really
impressed by what they landed her with
because I thought they might have they
might have landed her on a much darker
spot as I liked how she was even pushing
away uh Gap got huh Gap I think Gap uh I
like how she kept pushing GOP
away as she wanted to murder this guy
and he even had to be on his own and he
wasn't even feeling rejected I loved his
performance of how he was just the new
guy in this Demon World and was just
trying to prove himself so he had it
like this charming affable quality to
him who tried to oversimplify things and
didn't oh didn't push his desperation to
get this done too much like he just
tried keeping it light-hearted the whole
time it was refreshing it was this kind
of dynamic I feel like I've seen in
other B movie horror films not exactly
you know specific one to one but
normally they would go for a little bit
more of a dread heavy and make that guy
a lot more serious and stoic and maybe
just like sinisterly charming and they
didn't do any of that they flipped
everything on its head yeah and they
even had this Con I never really thought
about it because
um
I
i s the first time I ever really
understood that there was a large Indian
population in Britain
was when we saw Bennett Like Beckham and
so I wasn't really attuned to anything
historical or present at all going on
break again I was like we're like
[__] like 10 or 11 or something so I
didn't really know anything and that was
when I first became a tune to it and I
didn't ever really factor in what the
racism
experience and oppression must have felt
like for them and and so they had all
these neat ingredients in this little
Boiling Pot recipe to make you go
there's a lot of justifications of how
she could have just gotten pushed to a
Breaking Point and just blaming on them
they even set up this little tease about
my they thought my mom was crazy but I'm
actually crazy
uh it was it was smart it was really
really smart I think even though they
don't leave with commentary more most of
the time they they still leave with the
character
and they did an excellent job here uh
and and use its aesthetic and backdrop
of
70s uh horror exploitation ish Vibes uh
I thought it was just going to be
gimmicky at the beginning and then it
made me forget about all that the second
the demon speaks for the first time I
was like okay like you know you're
either gonna lose me or not and and I
think you know as I think something like
that you know you think of demons as one
thing and so the easy undercut is to
have him you know talk Cockney and and
you know
like anybody else but I thought that
they actually managed to like I love the
tunes of his performance because he
really towed a nicely sort of murky line
between charm and manipulation and that
I think fuels so much of the the
question mark again of you know is this
real is this not real is he just trying
to egg her on to you know corrupt her
spirit and all that talk about you
needed to be a corruptable person not
Beyond corruption and not already
completely corrupted and
touching on things that are sort of
latent you know it's like she has those
fantasies about you know bashing her
co-workers head in or the you know the
you know manager of their shoe
department or whatever
um and you know acknowledging that that
exists within and yeah going so far as
to find where it fits almost within her
personality or how she might look if she
embraced it without yeah just going
full-on absurd like just like the
fantasy you know like violent rage and
then doing like Gore for the sake of
Gore like I thought this episode managed
to have like the the kind of shocking
Thrills and the sort of grindhouse
flourishes that you would like but also
it never got lost in just having too
much fun with those things and and like
yeah that whole bit between the
politician and the the other girl you
know the the
crappy uh you know super mean shoes shoe
sales girl or whatever like that whole
thing where he's just explaining to her
that like yeah like the system only
works in this one particular way sort of
and I'm gonna take those values and I'm
gonna snake them my way into you know my
best chance of actually winning of
gaming the system and I just thought it
was funny that they made so much out of
that character and whether or not you
could take him out and kill him and I
love that that morality play turns into
like a true
sort of inversion because yeah it's like
she could just kill her co-workers She
Could Just Kill the manager but you know
like it's like how can I take this curse
and make it as like effective in a
positive way as I can or at least use it
to remove that much more suffering like
how can I make this trolley problem work
for me and I thought that was a great
scene because it is like something that
you could easily kind of lose to the
strangeness of the moment but uh but
yeah then it's like you have this actual
demon this guy who's actually in a very
physical Way Towing that murky line of
charm and manipulation but in like an
overtly evil way whereas like yeah the
the demon
it does kind of pose like a fun sort of
question mark as well about yeah
who's the lesser of the evils here and
whatnot
um but yeah yeah just like their
interactions back and forth and the the
changing of their Dynamics just every
beat was so lovely and uh yeah their
their Harmony and watching as they trade
kind of in who's doing more of the
talking and the having more of the
confidence is just so gradual and nicely
handled
yeah and I love the cop too the the cop
was very
sympathetic empathetic and
you could feel this
is you feel the experience in the most
simplistic terms I would say uh you can
feel this the horrors this guy has
witnessed and
obviously is the one one of the few
who's not racist in the characters that
we follow and
I love the Nuance to his performance of
he yeah he's got to catch the Killer
but there's this part of him that can
understand even without knowing much he
can connect with her
in a in an unspoken manner
just find bits of information and
conclude a possible history as to why
this person is the way they are and what
might even lead this person to do what
they do
the way I was very effective
and he starts off as like a guy who
doesn't really give a [__] to an
individual who
gives the motions and I thought that was
I thought that was really well executed
I think I think they inhabited this
world really well that I think each
each episode here presented
um a fervent eye to it all I thought it
was a lot of passion on display from
beginning to end
though the one that had the most just
fun I think like stream Berry well I
think is the most talked about one
um it's the most on that's actually my
least favorite the first one was
actually my least favorite of them all
um and and then I would probably go with
Beyond the Sea I would go I don't know I
would say that in order for favorites
I'll go this one
Beyond the Sea lock Henry
yeah amazing day amazing day and then
John is awful and then Joan is awful
yeah that would be my ranking my
personal ranking of them all uh I think
that these I thought it was a great
season and yeah each episode left
truly left an impression on me
um yeah and I think just looking at the
whole thing even though it's an
anthology I thought the different
lengths I thought each episode was
proportioned well unto itself and a lot
of people have slagged off uh Maisie day
especially for being like yeah short and
like the least deep but even that one I
thought like nicely inhabited what it
was supposed to be and for a season like
this with a couple feature-length
episodes I'm like yeah do one lean and
mean do one that's like an actual you
know dramatic feature and then yeah do
something like this that is like both
fun and filled with abandon but also you
know focused and graceful in surprising
and unexpected ways and and yeah like
for a season again that seems like it's
wanted to train uh change some things or
at least try some new flavors out I
thought that was a successful experiment
kind of across the board and I thought
that a lot of the principles I have kind
of just been taking from these changes
have been sort of well embodied by this
episode across the board in particular
well guys what'd you think about Black
Mirror what would be your favorite of
the five leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe leave a like thank
you for everyone who joined us on this
journey but before we go let's end this
with a patreon
Lex I think you would make a good Demon
and I would listen to all of your input
and advices and uh you know I I like to
think that I'm a relatively you know
morally inclined person but if anybody
could corrupt me I imagine that it would
be you all right your persuasive you
you're friendly but uh who knows what
you could be thinking and what you could
be latently influencing me to do and uh
and I like you know not to have uh too
much culpability for my own
circumstances and decisions so if I
could just Pawn all that stuff onto you
and you know I know you'll have my back
you know if I'm ever caught or anything
like that so I think this could be the
start of a beautiful friendship
beautiful working relationship so uh
yeah I'm just putting that out into the
universe take some my blood and let's
make a pact uh that you know you'll
staple that'll be the things like you'll
stay pledged but for your pledge money
I'll sacrifice anybody you want
and that's a fact Jack you can take that
to the bank we love you my dear and stay
well
we'll talk soon
[Music]